2004's saw was a career-making movie for
many people
whether their roles were large or small
many of the actors in this
little horror movie that could either
had or went on to have
surprising careers we want to play a
game called
what happened to the cast of saw carrie
ellis is probably
best remembered for his dashing and
deadpan performance in the princess
bride
but he's also played a lot of jerkish
self-centered foils
as in twister and creepy antagonists
as in kiss the girls saw split the
difference
casting him as the selfish jaded dr
gordon
who has to spin the film growing into
someone viewers will root for
lawrence gets put through the ringer and
his suffering and character growth gives
elvis the chance to deliver a juicy
and intense performance you can call it
over the top
and plenty of critics did but elvis
sells it
i've done it now show them to me
so what's he been doing since then for
starters he returned to the franchise
and saw 3d another jigsaw victim who
converted to the killer's philosophy
outside of that
he's worked steadily usually releasing a
handful of films each year
with appearances in 2019's black
christmas remake
stranger things season 3 and the
acclaimed
ghost light he seems to have found a new
home in horror which tends to be loyal
to its favorite stars
best of all he also landed a role in
mission impossible 7
bringing him into one of the most
solidly entertaining franchises around
saw co-creator lee winnell's acerbic
vulnerable atom is a key part of what
makes the first
saw movie work but he's arguably even
more important as the screenwriter
while winnell's acting career has stayed
small
mostly limited to fun supporting roles
in the insidious franchise
and horror films like the bye bye man
he's become a horror staple
as a writer and director he stayed on
with saw for a while
writing or co-writing the scripts for
the second and third movies
and then moved on to the clever
supernatural thrills of the insidious
movies
his directorial debut on insidious
chapter 3 got an uneven reception
but with 2018's sci-fi action film
upgrade he started knocking it out of
the park
with the release of 2020's widely
acclaimed the invisible man
the sophisticated and pulse-pounding
film starring elizabeth moss juanelle
officially became one of the most
exciting horror directors to watch
danny glover needs no introduction with
the lethal weapon series and predator 2
under his belt
plus roles in prestigious films like the
color purple
silverado and the royal tenon bombs he's
a household name
with saw's low budget it's impressive
the film snagged him at all
he plays tap a former detective who
becomes obsessed with proving that dr
lawrence gordon
is the jigsaw killer his involvement in
the case gives viewers context for
jigsaw's
terrifying string of murders and his
investigation
further amps up detention glover's life
and career have been as busy as ever
he's stayed deeply involved in activism
passionately advocating on issues
ranging from labor unions
to international affairs and civil
rights his filmography since saw's
release
has continued to be an impressive blend
of critical and commercial successes
artistic risks and guaranteed crowd
pleasers
basically danny glover can do anything
and he's proved it by doing everything
in some jam-packed and incredibly
successful years
ken leung's doomed detective stephen
singh
might meet a bad but undeniably
memorable
fate and saw but ken liang has luckily
done much much better in life
he was a little bit of a name before saw
especially given
his villainous turn in rush hour but he
found some of his most notable career
successes after detective singh
died in a shotgun trap in particular he
attracted a lot of attention for a
memorable guest starring spot on the
sopranos
that the washington post pegs as being
one of the turning points in his career
he went on to play series regular miles
on lost
a fan favorite character from the back
half of the show's run
that many viewers wish they'd gotten to
see more of liang
also had recurring roles on the
blacklist and
zero hour and was a series lead on
medical drama
the night shift his film work hasn't
been quite as high profile
but it's still been impressive with
roles in star wars the force awakens
spike lee's heist thriller inside man
and noah bombox
the squid in the whale dina meyer has
been a familiar face to genre fans for
years
appearing in everything from the satiric
starship troopers
to star trek nemesis she was even a
series lead
in 2002's birds of prey playing a
hard-boiled detective in saw
probably seemed like a natural move for
her career the film wound up doing a lot
for her
for one thing she would go on to become
a major part of the franchise
appearing in saw 2 and 3 and staying a
continuing part of the series lore
in 4 5 and jigsaw aside from the saw
series
most of meyer's major work has been on
tv with guest spots on almost
every show you could think of ncis los
angeles
the magicians criminal minds csi
and more in the first saw film mike
butters plays
paul the man who died in jigsaw's razor
wire trap
paul might meet his grisly fate in the
first movie
but butters still gets flashback
appearances in
soft 4 and 5 but he could have had an
entirely different
fate in the saw series as he told
vulture
originally the role i was offered was
jigsaw which
as you know in the first script really
did not have a whole lot to do
so i kind of said no which was probably
a mistake
it's intriguing to play what if and
wonder what butters could have done with
the part
paul gutrecht gets one of the worst
hardest to avoid deaths in saw
having to walk on broken glass holding a
candle while smeared in flammable jelly
to figure out how to get an antidote
for poison that's already in his veins
that's a very rigged game
and it's not surprising mark loses saw
was gutrec's final movie appearance
before he went on to pursue
another career as a licensed therapist
but he did have several guest starring
roles on tv
in particular he was a favorite of
showrunner matt nicks
who used him in burn notice the good
guys and complications
michael emerson who plays fake out
villain and reluctant jigsaw accomplice
zepp hindell wound up having one of the
most interesting post saw careers of the
whole cast while he appeared in a few
more movies
emerson's strongest work has been on tv
where he's found
several awesome intriguing roles that
really showcase his talent
even before saw emerson had an emmy
award-winning
guest star run on the legal drama of the
practice
but it was only after saw that his
career really took off
he was cast as ben linus on lost and the
part
catapulted him to national recognition
his work has been
one of another emmy this time for
outstanding supporting actor in the
drama series
emerson undeniably made the most of his
lost
success going on to star in the
thought-provoking sci-fi thriller series
person of interest the historical
miniseries the name of the rose
and the supernatural horror drama evil
truly a geek
icon benito martinez's brett has
one of the safest roles in saw he plays
lawrence gordon's lawyer and he gets in
and out without attracting
any of jigsaw's ire he even gives solid
legal advice
and once brett escaped martinez
continued an impressive career that's
made him one of tv's
low-key mvps he was already starring on
the shield
where he played the calculatingly
ambitious
david aceveda and he continued in that
role
until the show ended in 2008 drawing off
his great work there he's become a kind
of sleeper hit on
cable shows and some of the darker
network dramas
with prominent roles on sons of anarchy
house of cards
american crime the blacklist how to get
away with murder
and 13 reasons why he hasn't worked on
as many movies
but he's still been a part of some great
projects including queen and slim
beyond the lights and million dollar
baby
shawnee smith's amanda is one of the
most memorable characters in saw
even with very limited screen time her
desperation is vivid
and she's absolutely mesmerizing as
someone who has fallen
under jigsaw's spell the series knew
that her character had promise
and that smith who had an established
acting career
especially on tv was a good bet she
became a huge
part of the franchise with major roles
in saw two
and three game over
her future saw appearances especially
with her significantly expanded part
helped make smith into a little bit of a
horror name
it led to her hosting the reality show
scream queens in 2008
where she took young actresses through a
competition to win a role in saw six
but unlike a lot of saw actors she
didn't completely redirect her career to
horror
with previous work on shows like becker
she still had one foot in comedy
and her most significant post saw work
has come on the
fx sitcom anger management as the
menaced
and terrified daughter in saw mackenzie
vega doesn't necessarily have much to do
but to be fair she was around 10 when
the movie was filmed
in the wake of the film she went on to
grow up and develop as an
actor eventually demonstrating some
pretty strong dramatic chops
she really made a splash on the hit cbs
show the good wife
where she played series regular grace
the opinionated and independent daughter
of lead
alicia florek monica potter imbues
alison gordon with a sense of steely
poise even though she spends most of the
movie
fearing for her and her daughter's lives
a few years after saw
she would play another memorable horror
wife and mother
this time in the 2009 remake of the last
house on the left
most of potter's career however has been
in television
saw overlapped with her time as a series
regular on boston legal
where she played lawyer lori coulson
after a few years hopping around between
intermittent projects including a
regular role on tnt's
short-lived trust me she found
spectacular success with nbc's
parenthood
which gave her a chance to really shine
her nuanced performance as christina
braverman won her a critic's choice
award in 2013.
since the show wrapped she's continued
to work in tv
including a lead role on wisdom of the
crowd
poor jeff ridenour narrowly misses one
of the most
humiliating deaths in the franchise
jigsaw
uses him as a test subject for a trap
it's not even about him
and the detectives who discover him
decide to hang back
and see what jigsaw will do with him
before they step in
not exactly great police work ned
bellamy
the actor who played him has gotten
better treatment as he's developed a
career as a character actor
as a guest star he feels like a seamless
part of the ensemble on
everything from scrubs to justified to
treme
and he's had a pleasantly varied movie
career with roles in django unchained
and twilight alexandra chun plays
carla the medical student lawrence has
an ill-advised affair with
after saw she went on to have a strong
career that's only getting better over
time
her biggest movie role so far has been
as the lead in 2013's
innocent blood a well-regarded indie
thriller
and she's done a lot of tv guest star
work appearing on beloved shows like
house the event the magicians and agents
of shield
recently she's gotten more substantial
recurring roles
on both twitch's semi-interactive
artificial
and the netflix ballet drama tiny pretty
things
i want to play a game even before saw
tobin bell had built an impressive body
of work
he was someone you could spot in
everything from tutsi to goodfellas
in part because he appreciated any
chance to get on set
as he told movie line i viewed it as an
opportunity to make 150
a day doing something that i cared a
great deal about
where i could learn saw changed all that
splitting his career into before and
after stages
speaking with the orlando sentinel he
called the movie a great blessing
and he starred in multiple saw sequels
appearing in
every installment even after his
character's death in saw
three understandably he's now best known
as a horror actor
so he's also appeared in other horror
projects like
12 feet deep belzabeth and shudder's
creepshow
but he still occasionally gets to
stretch himself including with voice
work on cw's the flash
you have no idea what's about to begin
with this role in the franchise wrapping
up he's eager to see if his increased
star power can translate to different
kinds of roles
one's very far from john kramer we hope
he'll never leave
horror behind completely but after years
of masterfully orchestrating terror for
audiences everywhere
he certainly deserves a change of pace
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you